ipp ports college of fifth and be
prosthesis pip the film commission
president notes remarkable softwarehouse
and leap of species for a Venetian challenges
separated a hundred indeed we can't
go wrong with sco venice which also
manifests itself reyer ne shoots the
firm os that the planet its  future is
tired we could not be wrong the
storms could be thanks to our
pressure it has widened to the bottom to
wear it out more equal commission
of the history our group will serve by
giving the battle for the aj look
son-in-law not only and in the number of
carbons we note the environment and the  politics must be
called to cable one of the gas of real
beings attempt to get by with the cra
of nazi violence with a european directive i
don't have to simonson cup hable of
cereri politik basile and emigration
to 89 del nova and it is built in
politics as you know everything  us on the
cloud and durability effective manor measure
and the web of the de force blue
versus and partenavia included in the media
company tent
[Applause]
having a different approach
polemical critic alternative to born madam
president is not the same thing
within these institutions
we must clarify these positions
on this we want
a position of clarity from the president's commission
politicians are invited to  sirjan of empoli titan
online sales visual
export guarantee